заганяю евакуації заливкою поки що
волосся або вони тут у 130
кілометрах у вигляді лінії розмежування
активного tuition примати біженців у
тему санаторіїв ж посилилася про пощаду
sitter осип який виїхав з авдіївка сама
стіна з 2013 року
ті ж 4 евакуація для Ірини двічі
audi лку обстрілювала дуже сильно
йдуть бої йдуть бої німа впав і не світла
бушприт людина привезла з сам поїхав
на витратах на олексі тестів чика ти
загальна евакуація сама на владному авто
вив'язати гнучкою свою батьківщину.
знайомих витрати на житло то харчування
взяв на себе один вниз цілих блондин їх
зрозумів ну ка на дав їжу kinder тижня
далі вбити а ще обидва вміститися лаву
дайте обами не все одно кухар, то ти сюди
дому на роботу а дружину з датного чоловіка
воду риге всі граматики організації
прифронтових краматорська то слов'янська за
вирощувала дуба вода допомагає тим хто
поїхав за білкою і тим, хто ж завищується
разом Наталія займаєте батьком старший
Адже днів під шапку бойових дій на
донбасі найбільша проблема з
продуктами нам є риба року вати а
року вати нічого немає простіше на хід шуваю
біженців та їх можна буде лише тисяч
показ бюджет вона виділена теж
гуманітарний з тивні vantage суди у
азоті волонтери син зберігав всі шви
знаючи наталі влада тяга разу питала
пак апарат і знову книжку сич ньому але
лаура ляльки могилку також обстрілював і
в принципі, в принципі держава готова
Дупа магате людям зустрічатися і їх мало
того проживання наставить сотки в будо
сплачено обладміністрації та реєстрації
після тагір скуповувалося calls the base
with лагодження sd більше виліт його які з
їх реально готові про мене людей
друга та й перевіряють з перу битники
міжнародних місій деякі центри
масі бейки центри ми висували там че
потрібну wing ну ти впав і не знову
буду вати сяду прийому в інших результаті наше
завдання подивитись скільки конкретно
людей світлоярськ готові прийняти
які у молоді потрібно пит ринку
допомога оддержк а допомога заданим гру
травнева організація світлоярська
тут може розміститися на боже і тисячі
всі путін влада правди знає і тут беша
місяць першингу для дітей перших 100 ма
liceul живі біля за дівкою